-Here's what people
are talking about.
The big story
is still Trump's physical.
[ Laughter ]
Which he passed with
flying colors.
-Yeah.
-Surprisingly, yeah.
A lot of people were very
skeptical when they heard that
Trump only weighs 239 pounds.
[ Laughter ]
That actually checks out when
you remember that
for the weigh-in, Trump took off
his clothes and his hair.
So I mean, that's...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Makes sense.
-It balances out.
So they say Trump hopes to drop
10 to 15 pounds this year...
while Melania hopes to drop 239.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Ho!
Ho! Hey! Ho!
-This surprised some people.
Trump's doctor says he got
a perfect score on the
Montreal Cognitive Assessment,
which is a test that examines
someone's mental clarity.
Well, we got our hands
on Trump's answers,
and I think that they may have
gotten a little --
They've gone a little easy
with him with the grading.
-Really?
-I think, well,
just take a look. I don't know.
The first question was,
"what is similar about a grape
and an orange?"
Trump said, "they're both types
of soda."
[ Laughter ]
It's correct, but --
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
He's right, I mean...
-Next, they asked,
"what is 30 minus 7?" Trump
said, "my approval rating."
[ Laughter ]
And he --
-Whoa!
-This is...
And then they said,
"draw a square."
Trump drew a doodle
of Mike Pence.
It was actually a good drawing.
-Oh, my.
-A good drawing, though.
-Very good drawer.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
Next, they asked, "what is
the name of this animal?"
Trump said "Mufasa."
[ Laughter ]
-Not wrong.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-And finally, they asked,
"what's the name
of this animal?"
Trump said "boobasaurus."
Well, I mean you got one --
one wrong. One wrong
out of the whole thing.
-No, no, that's not bad.
-Not bad.
This is pretty big. Today,
Senator Jeff Flake gave
a big speech
on the Senate floor,
and he compared President Trump
to Russian dictator,
Joseph Stalin.
Trump said, "why, because we
were both elected by Russians?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
After he was accused of making
racist remarks in a meeting
last week, Trump tweeted
that his approval rating
among black voters has doubled.
That story again.
[ Laughter ]
Two times zero is still zero.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Just so you know.
Doubled. "Doubled."
This morning, Eric Trump went on
"Fox & Friends" and passionately
defended his father, while at
home the President was like,
"where do I know that guy from?
I like him. I like him a lot."
[ Laughter ]
You guys see this?
Yesterday in Japan, someone sent
a false alert
about a North Korean missile.
Then the guy who sent it said,
"yeah, I might have lied
"about why I left my last job
in Hawaii. Sorry!
Uh, Oops! Sorry!"
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this, I saw that
the UK just appointed
a Minister of Loneliness.
[ Light laughter ]
The UK just appointed
a Minister of Loneliness.
Yeah. To deal with the sad
reality of modern life. Yeah.
Minister of Loneliness.
As if Morrissey wasn't enough.
[ Laughter ]
They named him
Minister of Loneliness.
[ Laughter ]
Even worse -- even worse,
she's the only person
in the world with that job.
I mean, how sad!
How sad is that?
[ Laughter and applause ]
The only person --
can't relate to anyone.
Finally, I want to say --
You liked that Morrissey one?
Yeah, I know, thank you,
thank you.
-That was classic.
It was classic.
-Finally, I want to say congrats
to Kim Kardashian and Kanye West
who just welcomed a baby girl
this week.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah! Yeah.
-I don't have a joke for that.
I just want to think back
to the good old days when that
would have been our lead story.
There you go.
We have a great show tonight.
Give it up for The Roots,
ladies and gentlemen.